we have been starting to pay closer
attention to particular 2022 midterm
races we're following
just to name a few
the florida gubernatorial race where
potential 2024 presidential candidate
ron desantis is up for re-election as
governor
we on monday night
had a live stream of in the pennsylvania
senate we first had the democratic
primary debate and then we had the
republican primary debate the republican
primary debate is the one where memit oz
the um
uh
tv doctor is running we covered that and
it was cringy and it was wacky in a lot
of different ways
another particularly disturbing race is
the arizona house race
wherein in the first arizona
congressional district a guy named ron
watkins is running we've talked about
ron watkins before
ron watkins is a
a roughly 35 34 year old conspiracy
theorist he's the site administrator
administrator and um
i guess we i think he's the owner as
well
of the website 8k un this is formerly 8
chan
and he has played a major role in
spreading
all sorts of far right q anon conspiracy
theories he is now running
in arizona's first congressional
district he was in a debate last night
hosted by arizona state university and
the local pbs station and there is
something about this guy
that is
cringe-worthy and extraordinarily creepy
i don't know exactly what it is i'm
going to look at a couple of clips here
with you first just a very strange
moment from his opening statement where
he kind of seems to lose his train of
thought but it's all just weird and i
will make sure that your rights are
are kept
thank you okay
so the enti the entire thing got off to
a very very strange start
now then the question of ukraine came up
military aid to ukraine ron watkins
tried to blame the keystone xl pipeline
for the invasion
and this um
uh led to one of the other candidates
representative blackman
to basically crush watkins and he
crushed him so brutally that watkins had
no choice to go actually i misspoke my
opponent is correct this is fascinating
check this out terry aid to ukraine what
do you think ron i support military aids
ukraine but i want to say that we would
not even be in ukraine if president
biden did not shut down the keystone
pipeline on the first day why
because
now that that's shut down we have to get
our oil and we're getting it from russia
and we're getting
all these problems through the ukraine
and that would not have happened if
biden did not so you see the ukraine so
this is a word salad this is of no he is
visibly struggling to use english to
communicate substance and he is failing
the
the pipeline
helped prompt russia to invade ukraine
yes sir because we've got all of this
oil coming through from russia to the
united states and
they want the better routes to bring the
oil through can i can i clarify
this is what i'm talking about that's
not why they went into ukraine ukraine
they went into ukraine because ukraine
didn't want to be part of nato listen
you're trying to be you're trying to
work on the national stage and you don't
even know why the war started in ukraine
it had nothing to do with the keystone
pipeline the keystone pipeline caused
the the inflation and the increase in
our gas prices now that reason why
that's also not true that so they're
both wrong but but i mean this this is
just bizarre they went in to ukraine is
because russia
wanted ukraine as they had him pre-world
war ii and ukraine wanted to be part of
nato respond please
he's right i made a mistake yeah there
you go so i mean
listen
if there's anything to praise ron
watkins for here
um
it's that he immediately said yeah what
i just said is completely untrue it's
absolutely and completely untrue in
another weird moment ron watkins claimed
that the biggest issue in uh the
congress is is it the first or second
congressional dis now i don't even
remember they he said that the biggest
issue is the border wall even though
this part of arizona isn't actually near
the border and then he claims that he
went to the border and scared coyotes
away coyotes not literal
actually i think he means coyotes in
terms of like people smugglers i don't
think he means literal coyotes but let's
listen biggest issue for this district
is the border wall the border wall was
not completed and there are actually
sections of it that were destroyed
and i went down to those sections and i
asked the locals how did this section of
the border wall get destroyed right and
they told me that biden sent the army
corps of engineers down there to destroy
the border wall for flood for flood
prevention
issues so i went down there and i saw
with my own eyes i saw the coyotes
sitting right across the border the
coyotes looked me in the eyes and they
ran away right they were so scared when
when uh ron watkins went down there so
bizarre stuff and lest anybody think
that ron watkins is the only wacky
candidate
then the moderator asked representative
walt blackman about his history of
wanting to
uh charge
people women seeking abortions and the
doctors performing them with homicide
and he says he still supports that so
it's not only ron watkins that's off the
rails i read that you have said that you
said abortion doctors and women who get
abortions should be charged with
homicide exactly you know that's already
in our statute the arizona statute if a
person commits abortion or kills a baby
while in the womb it's under our
criminal statute i didn't make the law
up the law has already been there what i
did was qualify that law now
going back and changing that and
amending that what i have done is allow
women to be able to seek services
counseling services
for what they need now here's the deal
so basically he's willing not to charge
women with murder
if instead they go to one of these
counseling services
where
the by the way the term counselor is not
a regulated term it's not a therapist
where they go to like a christian
counselor who talks you out of getting
the abortion there are more babies being
aborted and born every day now the
problem that i see is that that is not
part of the conversation and if i have
to do something to save the black
community of babies being aborted in a
record number guess what i'm going to do
it but we need to save all babies when
we have states like california and new
york that are pushing late term abortion
that are pushing and fantasize and we
stand and do and remember no no one's
pushing it nothing it's time for us to
take a stand for life it's time for us
to get on the side of god and it's time
for us to protect these children that
are being murdered in the womb homicide
at what level how far did the pregnancy
be when it's homicide conception
conception conception yes sir okay can
you imagine
homicide
for a you know five-week abortion
this is this is some people don't like
this term this is dark ages uh dark ages
stuff
um okay one more clip the moderator asks
or one two more clips the moderator asks
ron watkins how would you have reacted
as a congressman on the day of the trump
riots i'll start with you how would you
have reacted
as a congressman on january 6th
on january 6th as a congressman i would
have
texted president trump and told him
please call this off
because it got out of hand pretty
quickly do you think he had the power to
do that
he did call it off but he took a while
to do this if he had the power to call
it off do you think he had the power to
call it on i don't know uh
so he had invited all these people out
there
and
surely
uh there must have been some kind of
intel going on but i don't i don't know
it was meant to be a peaceful uh protest
and there were some people that got in
there and did some bad things and
those people should be prosecuted the
ones that did the bad things but right
for the majority of the people that were
there 99.99
it was a peaceful protest and there was
no issue so 99.99 of the people that we
saw on television storming the u.s
capitol walking the halls defacing the
capital these were well i just told you
that there were people doing bad things
and there were millions of people there
and there was just a few people that
really i've seen oh yeah the people at
that uh rally and at the capitol
millions yes sir yeah there were not
millions of people there as of course we
all know um and then lastly here ron
watkins actually asked about his
relationship to q anon he just denies
the entire thing ron some people say
that a lot of this was stoked by q anon
what is your relationship with q another
i have no relationship with q anon none
at all not at all um the reports are
that your bulletin board sites hosted
postings that launched and launched a q
a on conspiracy so i ran a free speech
website and i was the administrator
and there were many thousands of
thousands of people that posted on those
sites
uh q was just one of those and i do not
know who it was and i'm not that person
yeah of course he spent months and
months and months parroting human on
stuff in uh cringeworthy fashion so the
closer we look at a lot of these
individual races it's all bad choices
it's bad and then worse and
unfortunately a lot of these people may
end up winning in november we'll have
these clips on our instagram at david
pakman's show who though for those who
are gluttons for punishment and want to
take a look at them
one of our sponsors is cheese butter
giving you 20
off cheese butter is a delicious gourmet
cheese melt that ingeniously blends four
indulgent cheeses and artisanal seasoned
butter i love this stuff cheese bud is
the type of thing you've got to try to
really understand there are so many
different things i was already putting
cheese and butter on but by combining
top shelf cheeses and butters together
cheese butter unlocks a new level of
tasty gourmet goodness and there are
actually several cuisines with sauces
that mix these ingredients it may be new
to you but it is a
tried and true combination very often
cheese butter will make an appearance
when i'm cooking at home i put it on
french and sourdough bread bagels
english muffins it's great on sandwiches
grilled cheese burgers baked potatoes
mac and cheese broccoli broccolini my
beloved broccolini other vegetables i'm
sure there's lots of other home chefs in
the audience who can come up with some
great ways to use cheese butter and
you'll now get 20 off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below